皆様こんにちは安東広島の渡辺智子と申し
ます今日どうぞよろしく
あのウクライナにロシアが侵攻しましたね
1年前にその時皆さんはどんなことをお
感じになりましたか
私は世界が激変したと思いました
本当に
歴史のターニングポイントに私たちは立っ
ていると思いました
でもその時思ったんですどうやって今の
世界を見ればいいんだろう
私考えたんですねどの視点で見ればいいん
だろう
このウクライナのロシアのウクライナ侵攻
で最も苦しむ人は誰なんだろう
それ考えましたそしてその最も苦しむ人の
起点でこの世界を見た時にどんな世界が
見えるだろうそしてそこに何か私ができる
ことがあるだろうか
そう考えて動き出しています
今日は
何か私にできること皆さんと一緒に考え
たいと思ってやってきました
私は安藤広島という団体を作ったんです
けどアントのもっとは
仲間とともに大地を
這う
一歩一歩客室に歩む
私と広島のつながりを皆様にご紹介します
皆さんが見ていただいているのは私の母
です
1945年8月6日広島の
赤十字病院の看護学校学生でし
た15歳
奇跡的に生き延びまし
た崩れた建物の中で一筋の光を見て
這い上がって生き延びたんですね
でも長く私の父も母も被爆者ですが当時の
ことを語りませんでした
私に息子ができてその子が小学校の時に
年齢おばあちゃん何があったの教えて
その時に初めて
母は少しずつ自分の体験も話してくれる
ようになりました
そしてかなり時間が経った後です
母は私にこのことを教えてくれました
私の祖父が
母を探して8月の6日
2日ぐらいですかね後に広島に入って母に
会ったそうですそして一言
馬や生きとったん
か私の祖父が言ったそうですそして家に
帰ろうって言ったん
ですだけど母は私は残ると
15歳の少女ですでも私がどうして残った
のって聞いたら私は
こうしてたくさんの人が
月を求めてきてる
老いて帰れんかった
んよその一言でした
私はそれから広島とは何かずっと考える
ようになりましたそして私は戦争も
原爆も知りません
だから知りたかった
一人でいろんな人に会っていろんなところ
に行って話を聞きました
今でも探しています
広島の意味を考えています
そして
亡くなった人の死の意味や今生きている
自分たちの生きてる意味考えるようになり
ました
そして私は今皆さん見てください2枚の
写真があります
廃墟になった広島1945年そして今の
広島私は平和に復興した後に生まれて育ち
ました
だけどあの廃墟になった広島と同じような
状況で
苦しんでそして
支援を求めていらっしゃる人がたくさん
いらっしゃいますね
ウクライナもそうですカンボジアもそう
ですね以前はねそして今シリアもそうです
たくさんのところでたくさんの人があの時
の広島のような状況で
苦しんでいらっしゃいます私思ったんです
何か私にできることがないだろうかと思っ
たんです
でも何をしたらいいかその時は本当に
わかりませんでし
たでもモヤモヤずーっと考えたんです
子供さんに言われました仕事もありました
でもずーっと考えた時に私は広島の経験や
体験を生かして平和を作る人になりたいと
思ったんです
そしてそのためにどっか場所があるかなっ
て探したんですけどなかったんで小さな
場所を自分で作りました
それがあんと広島です
そして本当に手探りで出会った人出会った
人のために何かできるかそう考えて
コツコツコツコツ10年くらい歩いてき
ましたその時にいろんな出会いがあって
きちんとした組織になって
活動した方がいいよ
仲間も増えました今アンと広島の
ミッションというですね5つあります
あんたはいつも人と人との絆をベースに
その人たちと一緒にやってます
仲間が少しずつ増えてます
仲間と一緒にやっています
去年実は変えたんですミッション
今の時代に合うものに変えようと思って
30何年経って買いました
被爆体験の継承してこのことをきちんと
世界に伝えたいでないと同じことが起きる
人が忘れてしまった同じこと起きますね
それから
核なき世界
核なき世界を実現したいそして新しい国際
秩序を作りたいと思ったんです小さな
あんたですでも思うことはできますそこに
向かって動くこともできます
そして平和で持続可能な世界への
転換を本気で促さないと2030年に
私たちの地球はどうなると思ったんですね
それから何よりも平和文化や平和教育を
広げたい
そして
平和の担い手を
育てるでもこれは新しい
仲間を作るということだと思っています
今日皆さんにご紹介するのはアントが最初
にやった海外のプロジェクト小さな
パキスタンのクリニックを作るという
小さなプロジェクトを紹介をします実は
20数年ずっと続けています
皆さん私がわかりますかアフガニスタあの
パキスタンの服着てますねその周りに
いらっしゃるのはアフガンダミッド
パキスタンの貧しい人です
ある時一通のメールを受け取ったんです
2002年ですね
智子見捨てられたアフガンダミンキャンプ
があるんだ
そこには人々が絶望してなんとか
命をつないで生きて
いる当時メディアはアフガン難民の人たち
はみんな母国に帰ったって言ってました
私はまさかと思いました
でも確かにあるんだというメールを受けて
なんだか私は行こうと思ったんです
たった一人で出かけました
初めてのパキスタンです降り立ったのは
ラホールという町の飛行場ですその時
パキスタンの友達まあパートナーですね
一緒にやってくれるパキスタンのNGOの
人が
迎えに来てくれて私の手を最初に取って
くれたのは小さな少女でした
その子が私の手を握ってくれた時に私は
本当に安心してそしてこれから先
パキスタンでいろんなことがあった時全部
その子が私にどうすればいいか教えてくれ
ました
一緒にアフガンダミンキャンプにも行き
想像を超える状況がありました
これが難民キャンプか
廃墟のようなところでしたね日がない
ところでそしてそこに
恋を潜めるようにして2万人の人たちが
生きていました
私は本当に何でここに来たんだろうと思い
ました
こんな私がこんな無力の私がどうしてここ
に来たんだろう本当に思って涙が止まり
ませんでした
でも
パキスタンの友人が小さな仏教遺跡のある
小高い丘に誘ってくれたんですね
私うつむきながらずっと登ってたんですね
そしたらアザーンというイスラムの今から
祈りの時間ですよっていう音楽が聞こえて
きてそこにパキスタンの人たちのおそらく
何千年といって変わらない生活が丘の上
から見ました
その時思ったんですねあー何千年も人間
って何か自分にできること
こうであったらいいなそしていろんな人が
努力して
でも
成功したばっかりじゃないですねいろんな
ことがあってもそうやって人は生きて今に
つないでるんだって思ったんです
そしたら私にできることをやろう
と最初に私がやったことは皆さんの様子を
映像や写真に撮って広島に帰って一人で
いろんなところに出かけて行ったり小さな
集まりの中で見捨てられた難民キャンプが
あるんですこの人たちここに生きてるん
ですだけど見捨てられてるんですって話し
て回りました
そしたら少しずつ共感してくださる人が
あって
そして私はまた翌年
意を決して国際保険の看護師さんと一緒に
仲間が一人できました一緒にパキスタンに
行きました
だけどこの辺境の地でこんな風にちゃんと
お医者様に見てもらえるような小さな
クリニックをどうやって作るんだろう
わからないのに行ったんですだから行って
調査しながら調査の方法も学びながら
一つずつどうやってプロジェクトを作るの
か学びました
JICAの専門家の意見も聞きました本当
にコテンパンに打ちのめされました
だけど諦めなかった
諦めることができなかったんですねそうし
てどうしてもあの暗闇の中で子供を出産
するあの女の人たちそしてそこで亡くなっ
てしまう子供たち
ペシャワールの街にまで行けば
病院はありますでも帰りには大きな借金を
買い背負って帰ってくる
この人たちが何か悪いことをしたわけでは
ない
何とかしたいと思いました
そして
やっぱり何回も何回も行きましたできる
ことありとあらゆることやってみました
私のそばに立ってるのは左端の男性お医者
様で私の隣のあの赤い洋服が見えるのが
女性のお医者さんですその隣は
看護師さんですねみんなでそのみんなで
いろんなことを手探りでやったんですが
どうしてもダメでした最後にJICAの
頼みの綱も
危険な地域ではどうしたってプロジェクト
を行うことはできないと言われました
私は決めました
謝るためにだけパキスタンに行こうと思っ
てたんですけど
だけどその時本当に不思議なことに1本の
電話がかかってきました
いらっしゃいと呼ばれましたある女性から
そして私はあなたを見ていたこのお金を
使ってください
多額の寄付をいただきました
嬉しかったですけどだけどすごい
席にを感じましたそのお金を背負って
パキスタンに行ってそしていよいよ
箸もハメとシャーという
族長のところに会いに行って土地をお借り
して建設を始めたんですでもまた
タリバンの制圧っていうことで空爆が
始まりました
建設途中の
働いてらっしゃる
労働者の皆さんパキスタンの皆さん
命が危なかったので
私は
断念しました
本当に2年間苦しかったです
あんなに大きなお金をいただいて
途中で全部なくなっちゃったんですね
でも
なんとかずっと何ができるか考えてました
そしたらある時電話がかかってきました
今度はパキスタンから電話がかかってき
ました
智子あの建物が残ってるよ地域の人が守っ
てる
よ私は嬉しかったですまたパキスタンに
行きました
そしてまたみんなでやろうでもお金は1円
ももう残っていませんでしたあんたは
小さな団体ですからお金ありません
じゃあもういろんな国の人たちと一緒に
協力してもう1回もう1回再建しようと
思ったんですねそしてアンと広島以外に
オーストラリアの需要やネパールのお医者
さんやいろんな方のそしてもう1回広島の
皆さんの
皮膚も募って小さなクリニックが7年の
うちに完成しました
今20年経っています地域の人たちにとっ
てはかけがえのない大事な
診療所になってますでも私は最初少しお
手伝いをしただけですあとはみんな皆さん
が自分たちに必要なものを自分たちの手で
努力して今日運営されてい
ます私はどうしてここまで
諦めずにやってきたのかなと思ったんです
そしたら私がたびたびアフガン難民
キャンプを
訪れた時に一人の女の子がとも
私はあなたが大好きよって言ってくれたん
ですねどうしてって聞いたらみんな1回
しか来ない
だけどあなたは何回も来るよねだから私は
大好きよ
私は本当に嬉しかったしその信頼に答え
たかっ
たこれだけだっ
た諦めるわけにはいかなかったと思ってい
ます
今あんたはいろんな仲間たちとともに
いろんなプロジェクトをやっています本当
にありです本当に小さいですでもたくさん
の人と手をつないで
協力して
しっかりと時間をかけて
信頼その絆を結んで
一歩一歩
活動しています今も変わらずやってます今
こんなに世界中から仲間が増えました
アフリカからもノルウェーからもいろんな
国の人がいろんな立場の人があんたに来て
それぞれみんなが何か私にできること
その力を合わせて今
活動を続けています平和を諦めたくない
です平和を作り続けたいと思います
皆さん一緒に仲間になってください私は
これからもありの歩みを続けます
今日はどうもありがとうございました
[拍手]